a briefcase full of poop changed my life
ten years ago I was a graduate student
and I was helping judge a genetic
engineering competition for undergrads
there I met a British artisan designer
named Alexander Daisy Ginsburg she was
wearing the white embroidered polo shirt
of the University of Cambridge team and
holding a silver briefcase like the kind
that you would imagine this handcuffed
to your wrist she gestured over from a
quiet corner and asked if I wanted to
see something with a sneaky look she
opened up the suitcase and inside were
six glorious multicolored turds the
cambridge team she explained had spent
their summer engineering a bacteria
e.coli to be able to sense different
things in the environment and produce a
rainbow of different colors in response
arsenic in your drinking water this
strain would turn green she and her
collaborator the designer James came
work with the students and imagined
different possible scenarios of how you
might use these bacteria what if they
asked you could use them as a living
probiotic drink and health monitor all
in one you could drink the bacteria and
would live in your gut sensing what's
going on and then in response to
something it would be able to produce a
colored output holy [ __ ] the cambridge
team went on to win the International
genetically engineered machine
competition or item for short and as for
me those turns were a turning point I'm
a synthetic biologist which is probably
a weird term that most people aren't
familiar with it definitely sounds like
an oxymoron
how could biology something natural be
synthetic how can something artificial
be alive so that a koala just sort of
poke holes in that boundary that we draw
between what is natural and what's
technological and every year Item
students from all over the world spend
their summer trying to engineer biology
to be technology they teach bacteria how
to play pseudo coup they make
multi-coloured spider silk
they make self-healing concrete and
tissue printers and plastic eating
bacteria up until that moment though I
was a little bit more concerned with a
different kind of oxy mom just plain old
genetic engineering the chameleon sign
Minori once wrote that genetic
engineering is actually insulting to
proper engineering genetic engineering
is more like throwing a bunch of
concrete steel in a river and if
somebody can walk across you call it a
bridge and so synthetic biologists were
pretty worried about this and and
worried that genetic engineering was a
little bit more art than science they
wanted to turn genetic engineering into
real engineering discipline where we
could program cells and write DNA the
way that engineers write software for
computers that day ten years ago started
me on a path that gets me to where I am
now today I'm the creative director at a
synthetic biology company called ginkgo
bio works creative director is a weird
title for a biotech company where people
try to program life the way that we
program computers but that day when I
met Daisy I learned something about
engineering
I learned that engineering isn't really
just about equations and steel and
circuits it's actually about people it's
something that people do and impacts us
so in my work I try to open up new
spaces for different kinds of
engineering how can we ask better
questions and can we have better
conversations about what we want from
the future of technology how can we
understand the technological but also
social and political and economic
reasons that GMOs are so polarizing in
our society can we make GMOs that people
love can we use biology to make
technology that's more expansive and
regenerative I think it starts by
recognizing that we as synthetic
biologists are also shaped by a culture
that values real engineering more than
any of the squishy stuff we get so
caught up in circuits and what happens
instead of computers there we sometimes
lose sight of the magic that's happening
inside of us there's plenty of shitty
technology out there but this was the
first time that I imagined poop as
technology I began to see that synthetic
biology was awesome
not because we could turn cells into
computers but because we could bring
technology to life this was technology
that was visceral an unforgettable
vision of what the future might hold but
importantly it was also framed as the
question is this a kind of future that
we actually
want we've been promised a future of
Chrome but what if the future is fleshy
science and science fiction help us
remember that we're made of starstuff
but can it also help us remember the
wonder and weirdness of being made of
flesh biology is us it's our bodies it's
what we eat what happens when biology
becomes technology these images are
questions and they challenge what we
think of as normal and desirable and
they also show us that the future is
full of choices and that we could choose
differently what's the future of the
body of beauty if we change the body
well we have new kinds of awareness and
will new kinds of awareness of the
microbial world changed the way that we
eat the last chapter of my dissertation
was all about cheese that I made using
bacteria that I swab from in between my
toes I told you that the poop changed my
life I worked with the smell or artists
and researchers Sissel told us to
explore all the ways that our bodies and
cheese are connected through smell and
therefore microbes and we created this
cheese to challenge how we think about
the bacteria that's part of our lives
and the bacteria that we work with in
the lab we are indeed what we eat the
intersection of biology and technology
is more often told as a story of
transcending our fleshy realities if you
can upload your brain to a computer you
don't need to poop anymore after all and
that's usually a story that's told us a
good thing right because computers are
clean and biology is messy
computers make sense and they're
rational and biology is an unpredictable
tangle it kind of follows from there
that that science and technology are
supposed to be rational objective and
pure and it's humans that are a total
mess but like synthetic biologists poke
holes in that line between nature and
technology artists designers and social
scientists show me that the lines that
we draw between nature technology and
society are a little bit softer than we
might think they challenge us to
reconsider our visions for the future
and our fantasies about
strolling nature they show us how our
prejudices our hopes and our values are
embedded in science and technology to
the questions that we ask and the
choices that we make
they make visible the waves that Science
and Technology are human and therefore
political what does it mean for us to be
able to control life for our own
purposes the artist Oren Katz and I nuts
are made a project called victimless
leather where they engineered a tiny
leather jacket out of mouse cells is
this jacket alive what does it take to
grow it and keep it this way
is it really victimless and what does it
mean for something to be a victimless
the choices that we make in what we show
and what we hide in our stories of
progress are some political choices that
have real consequences
how will genetic technologies shape the
way that we understand ourselves and
define our bodies the artist Heather
Dewey Hagberg made these faces based on
DNA sequences she extracted from
sidewalk litter forcing us to ask
questions about genetic privacy but also
how and whether DNA can really define us
how will we fight against and cope with
climate change will we change the way
that we make everything using biological
materials that can grow and decay
alongside us will we change our own
bodies or nature itself or can we change
the system that keeps reinforcing those
boundaries between science society
nature and technology relationships that
today keep us locked in these
unsustainable patterns how we understand
and respond to crises that are natural
technical and social all at once from
coronavirus to climate change are deeply
political and science never happens in a
vacuum let's go back in time to when the
first European settlers arrived in
Hawaii they eventually brought their
cattle and their scientists with them
the cattle roamed the hillsides
trampling and changing the ecosystems as
they went
the scientists catalogued the species
that they found they're often taking the
last specimen before they went extinct
this is the Maui how cow heavy or the
biskits alpha swill very honest so named
by Garrett Wilder in 1910
by 1912 it was extinct I found this
specimen in the harvard university or
barium where it's housed with five
million other specimens from all over
the world I wanted to take a piece of
Sciences past tied up as it was with
colonialism and all the embedded ideas
of the way that nature and science and
society should work together and ask
questions about Sciences future when
working with an awesome team at ginkgo
and others at the UC Santa Cruz we were
able to extract a little bit of the DNA
from a tiny sliver of this plant
specimen and to sequence the DNA inside
and then resynthesize a possible version
of the genes that made the smell of the
plant by inserting those genes into
yeast we could produce little bits of
that smell and be able to maybe smell a
little bit of something that's lost
forever working again with Daisy and
sisal tole asked my collaborator on the
cheese project we reconstructed and
composed a new smell of that flower and
create an installation where people
could experience it to be part of this
natural history and synthetic future
ten years ago I was a synthetic
biologist worried that genetic
engineering was more art than science
and that people were too messy and
biology was too complicated now I used
genetic engineering as art to explore
all the different ways that we are
entangled together and imagine different
possible futures a fleshy future is one
that does recognize all those
interconnections and the human realities
of Technology but it also recognizes the
incredible power of biology its
resilience and sustainability its
ability to heal and grow and adapt
values that are so necessary for the
visions of the future so we can have
today technology will shape that future
but humans make technology how we decide
what that future will be is up to all of
us
thank you
[Music]